tracking armored craft on a protein
ready
battle report enemy production crews are
destroyed reporting going mobile
since its potions gonna fire this place
spot a target fire will
enemy real gun firing on friends
alert sensor pose destroy
Harbor vehicle taking effective fire
armored vehicle has been destroyed
consul Armour eliminates this message
Keltie and reconnaissance force has
arrived but her point law repeat for one
long
Keltie an aircraft inbound it's a hot
Bell on deploy and here to intercept
unidentified more Gaussian forces have
entered contact range they're coming at
us from all sides ready destination our
armored vehicle block
enemy real gun eliminated
be by group your loss repeat Tuvok alert
Austin Strike Fighter in circulation
hostile light attack vehicles issue we
ought to Eddie arranges game targets on
sang alert sensor post law
the sensors post taking fire
Baumer any alert center both destroyed
all three Lander signals in the green
and on designated approach vector
we got something on the ride Brandi
waiting for eyes on to authenticate
don't take your eyes off the scanners
for a second don't displace you spot a
target fire at will
set to movement cleared hot sensors post
is under fire in a fasted heart
alert sensor post clock ready for orders
enemy armor tip enemy real gun firing
unfriend
enemy air strike in down
reporting Roger that coordinates
confirmed
alert center post destroy a turn counter
finding out
make ready target enemy light attack
vehicle marked on a protein copy that
bomber on deck send message set nias
down strike craft down read alert the
sit-in are approaching prepare to
rendezvous
carrier warning heat levels are spiking
and reroute power to avoid system damage
weapon range systems currently active
about a thousand with
very good point of men
fine to be going back on the horse
see you sighs exhausted hostile railgun
movin done
warning carrier remains and over here
Oh
damage assessment in carrier except for
damaged cars by over adjudged
one of our turret and taking fire